so thanks for dropping during the animal
oh good luck in your project yeah tank
tear my belly button
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
get those shoes
no there what I think they're brought
them right here they're absolutely
[Music]
so I'm not supposed to look at the
camera but you know I think you can look
into the camera basically ignore them
but look at them every months in a wad
well so you've been hitting this
conference pretty hard have you because
come across any stunning inside well
actually I came here last beginning of
last week because I was doing a workshop
in Munich and then I took the night
train here and had to spend about three
or four days here before the conference
because I wanted to see the conference
so my my main experience is actually the
experience of fraud I mean the
conference if it wasn't in Prague I
probably wouldn't go to it because the
speakers I've all heard before and but I
have not heard the Eastern Europeans so
I'm mostly interested in networking with
these the new Europeans and and really
getting a sense of Prague which to me
like a very impressive city and then
this whole political thing is happening
where the country is dissolving it's two
parts in in a relatively peaceful way I
think it's an incredibly dramatic thing
that's nothing I mean they're
demonstrating how to do it you know
unlike the Yugoslavs their neighbors
were demonstrating how not to do it and
some of the figures that like that stand
you know if you heard his talk on the
opening night when he was saying
Czechoslovakia has only lived without
foreign rule for 25 years out of the
last 300
and to think that somehow they have
managed when they've demonstrated in
this whole century such incredible
political sensitivity and Flair really
frustrating
yeah humor layer for survival and I've
been reading vaclav havel thoughts whom
I feel very close to and and I was
thinking about I visited this memorial
for that student John Pollock who
incinerated himself and 68-69 after the
Russians clamped back down and basically
the whole Prague Spring was killed
squelched and you know the lid came back
on after this two or three year period
of gradual falling and gradual opening
up and people breathing free for the
first time for 20 years and then
wham-o and then this was this to me but
struck me as a as a gesture of the like
selfs it was really like devotional
self-sacrifice to an ideal like what the
ancient Celtic and Germanic people used
to do in terms of and in assembling
similar circumstances like when they
felt that they were I like being invaded
or conquered or beaten up or oppressed
and they felt that somehow their gods
were against them and so they would do a
voluntary self-sacrifice you know and
and the sky is did that and haba keeps
talking about that he keeps talking
about I don't have a right to ask
anybody else to lay down their life or
do any kind of a commitment but that to
me the very live issue like what
commitment am I willing to make you know
am I willing to lay down my life am I
willing to go to jail for what I believe
in I can't ever ask it for somebody else
so here's a person who is really really
thinking the kinds of ethical questions
that people never think about
and I was impressed by the fact that
back in 1985 he was already talking
about
anthropocentrism which is the whole key
to what I'm talking about these days and
of humanists superiority complex the
main point I was trying to make a my
talk today was this is humanists the
humanism the humanist tradition which is
circles the glory of Western Western
European civilization is really the
shadow side of that which was not
intended and not realized at the
beginning when Renaissance humanism
started because these people like much
Helio 15e and those people I mean they
just they were trying to free themselves
from 1,000 years in medieval Catholicism
and we old men are just nothing that
sinners and miserable worms on the earth
and they said no human beings are
worthwhile and then Noble and is the
measure of all things but then implicit
in that was viewed man is superior to
animals right and that then gradually
kind of fed into the whole idea man a
superior animal that means we can do
with animals whatever we want to and it
kind of just reinforced that whole
Felisa so it was a provisional idea that
should have been replaced by a kind of
ecological ethic in the 19th century
well if you're gonna pick the company
yeah they took it too far I think see
the basic idea yes man is worthwhile
it's true but they didn't his man's
worth shouldn't be dependent on the
lower worth of somebody else like the
other species because but doing it that
way meant that you know humanism then
becomes exactly analogous to sexism and
racism and classism in each of which you
have one group of people who say we're
better than others this other group and
therefore we have the right to use and
exploit and dominate and control and
push these other on every way we please
you don't have to do that you couldn't
have say yes human beings are worthwhile
you know women are worth while men are
worth up to you know I'm the working
classes are great and so are the Sun no
higher which doesn't mean you can't have
division of labor or a division of
function and specialization of functions
and all that but don't attribute that
you know and also specialized Rawlings
yes human beings have a special role on
the planet
but then so do whales and so do for you
so it's all really invertebrate marina
also what you say that probably what
we're trying to do is define our special
role and that is not industrial
manufacturer of everything but more like
gardener carrot a partner can't taking
and I think to science I think this see
I go back to the biblical thing because
in the Bible there are actually two sets
of instructions from God God to man one
of the
is you shall subdue the earth and have
dominion and do all that whole thing
that was been interpreted as domination
and but there's another set of
instructions in the in the Yahweh's
Bible
see that's the priestly version the
older version did Yahweh's version which
is not just six days of creation it's
God created man directly out of the clay
breathed life into them and then created
the animals and made the garden and then
then he brought all the animals to Adam
and said you name them whatever you name
them that's what that's what they'll be
so the naming function I think human
beings are the nerve cells of the planet
and the nerve cells function to
interpret analyze categorize name that's
the one thing animal humans do that
animals don't do they don't give names
they have consciousness who's totally
different they don't have huge symbolic
categories as far as we know I mean they
can but a nervous system being simpler
is the rapid response that would be
green that would be to me green science
so observational science
non-interventional science science not
been to technology and exploitation
except insofar as is necessary to
maintain life and all people animals eat
other animals and so you have the right
to do that but but you don't have the
right to take more than you need right
you don't have to write it and you don't
generate waste like the primal cultures
they didn't generate they used all they
took and they didn't generate waste they
didn't take more than they needed they
didn't make profit they do it for profit
it's the difference to live
and with that kind of a system and that
common attitude you have a sustainable
you have a sustainable economy well so
this is one more reason for thinking
about semi archaic so the food to
moderate social problems that's what
abandoning science well to be abandoned
mean abandoning consumerism
I don't think it means abandoning
science I don't even think it means
abandoning technology I think it means
to be directing things no I agree it's
cat it's consumerism that has to be
consumerism is like a collective
addiction more and more goods from
normal people that's basically this
local at greater and greater profit yeah
cost to the sum total of somebody need
through here I think Rhian Eisler I
think that that was the key thing in her
book was that the level of culture does
not equate to the level of technology
the technology can be too sophisticated
as all get-out and the Sigma and the
culture is primitive and that's what we
have this is you take the Australian
Aboriginal Zorba the Minoan Crete is
their level of culture and technology
was much lower than ours but the level
of culture was much more superior right
now including things like education you
know levels of pot you know no poverty
no unemployment no crime on its kind of
thing so then technology needs to be
redirected away from the military
towards restoration and preservation and
restoration of the environment there's
more than enough challenges they had to
keep their you know all the star war
guys and you know everybody else
yeah I agree
well well I'm having a good time
good good you're having a good time
that's a good ray you'll see yourself in
lights at a theater near yes someday
soon yes so thanks for dropping right
the animal good luck yeah Tec Tec this
thing on my belly button here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]